[Musique]
alors c'est quoi une identité numérique
avec nous sébastien gang qui est
professeur au département d'informatique
de l'uqam bonsoir bonsoir l'identité
numérique qu'est ce que l'identité
numérique des citoyens alors son général
ça peut désigner deux choses soit le
fait qu'on ait une en d'identité en
ligne et qu'on puisse par exemple
accéder à des services et aussi en
général la possibilité de s'authentifier
par rapport à cette identité
ouais soyez plus précis jean touzeau par
exemple si on pense à au passeport
actuellement voyez ce qu'on a de danse
et des informations liées à notre
identité qui sont dans une carte à puce
sécurisée et qui peuvent être montrées à
la frontière pour prouver notre identité
donc on pourrait imaginer qu'on pourra
voir au québec une carte d'identité
nationale numérique qui auraient le même
type de processus dans une carte à puce
sécurisée vous auriez des informations
liées à votre identité mais qui pourrait
aussi permettre de prouver votre
identité à d'autres acteurs donc ça
pourrait être la banque leurs revenus
le système de santé par exemple mais ces
données-là l'état québécois a déjà
numérisé plusieurs de nos données
personnelles par lit tu passes par là
c'est l'état
il ya donc là on entend parler d'une
initiative provinciale c'est sûr que le
fédéral le fédéral a déjà la gestion de
l'identité qu'on pense au passeport là
l'idée ce serait peut-être d'avoir
l'équivalent mais gérée par la province
par exemple sur des attributs qui
dépendraient la la province donc on
pourrait imaginer qu on centralise par
exemple permis de conduire et la carte
d'assurance maladie sur cette identité
numérique donc qui pourrait prendre
plusieurs formes donc ça peut être une
carte à puce sécurisée mais on parle
aussi beaucoup d'applications sur
téléphones intelligents donc une carte
physique à puce wi dans lequel un peu
comme pour le passeport ou comme votre
carte de crédit on aurait une
information qui serait lié à votre
identité qui pourrait servir à vous
authentifier potentiellement pourrait
aussi utiliser d'autres façons de
vérifier avant que la carte à puce soit
débloquée de votre identité donc ça
pourrait être soit la biométrie soit un
nid par exemple la biométrie qu'est ce
que c'est la biométrie donc la biométrie
c'est l'ensemble des caractéristiques
physiques mais aussi comportementale
donc par exemple votre empreinte
digitale votre iris mais aussi votre
vitesse de frappe au clavier peuvent
être utilisés pour essayer de vous
authentifier
c'est une caractéristique qui est unique
donc on peut l'utiliser pour essayer de
vérifier l'identité où l'authenticité
d'une identité ou une plateforme en
ligne par exemple centralisée donc une
autre
une autre façon de faire ça pourrait on
pourrait imaginer que le gouvernement
centralise les systèmes gouvernementaux
par un système en ligne qui pourrait
être un une façon d'accéder à tous les
services donc par exemple le revenu le
casier judiciaire le fait de renouveler
son permis de conduire par un système où
le citoyen s'authentifie ray ensuite il
aurait accès à tous ces services là est
ce que ce type de solution là ce serait
pour tout le monde ce serait accessible
à tout le monde
si on combine la carte à puce
l'application sur téléphone la
plateforme en ligne
on pourrait aller vers des solutions ou
même si vous n'avez pas de téléphones
intelligents on peut imaginer que vous
avez d'autres façons de dhr d'utiliser
cette identité numérique donc là pour
l'instant il n'y a pas beaucoup de
détails sur quel va être larchitecture
mise en place par le gouvernement pour
l'identité numérique mais il ya des
façons d'essayer d'être le plus inclusif
possible
ça va nous protéger d'un vol de données
personnelles comme on a vécu
donc lhi dans l'idée principale
hanternoz sécurité c'est de pouvoir
avoir une meilleure preuve de l'identité
d'une personne en lui demandant de
s'authentifier donc si on prend par
exemple la carte d'assurance maladie
actuelle si je perds ma carte
d'assurance maladie et que quelqu'un me
ressemblent ils pourraient très bien
l'utiliser à ma place donc là on aurait
une une augmentation de gérer la
sécurité la validité de l'identité par
contre en fonction de comment on va
mettre en place cette identité numérique
il ya aussi des risques en termes de vie
privée et de liberté individuelle donc
cher il faut être relativement prudent
parmi toutes les solutions qui existent
sur la manière dont ça va être mis en
place c'est un dérapage potentiels
risques en particulier si le
gouvernement s'en va vers une solution
où les données sont centralisées
donc on imagine les données personnelles
de tous les ministères qui seraient
centralisés finalement des cons
centralise les données on s'expose à des
risques d'attaqué de fuites de données
et donc on pourrait s'exposer un des
jardins numéro deux en fonction de la
solution qui est mise
après il ya d'autres façons de faire ou
sur la carte à puce la biométrie
pourrait simplement être utilisé pour
pour valider la carte à puce pour lui
permettre de l'utiliser pour
s'authentifier y aurait pas forcément
besoin de stocker beaucoup de données
sur la carte à puce dont il ya des
solutions qui seraient beaucoup moins
intrusive et beaucoup moins risqué en
termes de vie privée
mais ce que le gouvernement s'est
renversé vers un système centralisé
ben c'est justement la question que je
me pose donc aujourd'hui à une annonce
d'une identité numérique mais ya pas de
détails précis sur l'architecturé
donc je pense que ce qu'il faut ça doit
être un débat de société
de savoir vers quelle solution on va
aller on peut aller vers des solutions
qui améliorent la sécurité en tout en
garantissant les libertés fondamentales
comme on peut aller vers une solution
qui serait centralisée donc pour vous
donner un exemple en inde
ils ont mis en place un système
d'identité numérique ou les données
personnelles de tous les citoyens ont
été colligés avec des données
biométriques il ya eu une faille de
sécurité donc ces données qui ont fuité
et donc là on se retrouve avec des
données de plus d'un milliard de
citoyens de l'inde qui sont disponibles
sur internet donc il faut absolument
éviter ce type de fierté oui mais c'est
ça donc la protection n'est pas totale
c'est ce que vous me dites élections
n'est pas totale bien cité numérique
mais on pourrait imaginer faire de
l'identité numérique on valide
l'identité de la personne mais sans
forcément avoir besoin de créer une base
de données centralisée donc on
utiliserait la carte à puce pour
s'authentifier mais sans que les
ministères par exemple les besoins de
centraliser toutes leurs données
personnelles dans un salon est donc
utilisé à certains endroits cette carte
là mais cinq non plus les toute
l'information soit disponible à ce
moment là oui et donc si on veut aller
plus loin il ya même des solutions qui
existent qu'on appelle des
accréditations anonymes qui pourrait
permettre de prouver une information
liée à son identité donc par exemple on
a le droit d' qu'on a un permis de
conduire mais sans forcément avoir
besoin de révéler son nom prénom son
adresse où toutes les données
personnelles
l'estonie a déjà procédé à
l'identification numérique de citoyens
est ce que s'y tenait un exemple à
suivre cela pense que c'est un exemple à
suivre alors il ya eu des failles de
sécurité en estonie mais les stones est
passé d'un donc c'est un petit pays mais
qui a pris une révolution numérique au
début des années 2000 mais qui a
justement fait un système de l'identité
numérique où les citoyens ont une carte
sécurisée qui branche dans un lecteur à
leur ordinateur et qui leur permet
ensuite d'accéder par exemple à leur
compte de d'impôt d'accéder aussi à tous
les documents administratifs de même de
renouveler une prescription donc eux est
clairement ils ont pris le virage
numérique ça a plutôt bien fonctionné
même si depuis vingt ans il ya eu
quelques failles quelques problèmes de
sécurité on va suivre ça de près avec
beaucoup d'intérêt sébastien garde merci
beaucoup si beaucoup de projets station
merci